let's go next to our caller from the two
four eight area code who's calling today
from two four eight ayat space from
Michigan hey ace what's going on hey
first of all love your show
started watching it listening to it
about a year ago thank you I just want
to say that so I had two questions one
was related to your previous callers the
black lives movement back when it first
started back when joy Floyd was killed I
think the public the majority of the
public had their support in terms of
police reform now it seems like it's you
know turning into a very vague and
doesn't really have a direction or
specifics of what the people want and I
don't know if that's going to be good
for the Democrats especially coming into
November in terms of getting rid of
police or defunding all police and
things like that I wonder if you can
comment on that second question
yesterday Biden at some event made a
statement that he would reverse most of
trumps tax cuts yeah how how much do you
think that will affect the the moderates
in terms of their support for Biden
because I know they're probably more
conservatives in terms of tax I mean
know nobody wants more taxes to pay more
taxes Biden you know he's been doing
great in the tools nationally and at
most states especially you know the
swing states even I think today Texas
he's even with Trump but do you think
making any comments about reversing tax
cuts would be bad for him I mean he's
just
why he's been doing great in the polls
just doing nothing but do you think that
helps her hurt them I think that his
comment about the tax cuts is not going
to have a big impact I think that right
now really what you have is a referendum
on coronavirus a referendum on the
economy as a result of coronavirus a
referendum on Trump's reaction to the
protests which has been abysmal and a
referendum essentially on Trump as the
laughingstock around the world that many
believe him to be so listen Joe Biden
has made it clear like nothing is going
to substantively change for the
privileged in the United States under
Joe Biden
so he'll reverse the Trump stack trump
tax cuts or or let certain provisions
expire the very rich will pay a few
points more but again nothing will
fundamentally change it's these are
really just slight tweaks so I think at
this point because this is such a
referendum on Trump I don't think that
the tax cut comment is really going to
meet be a huge different difference
maker we'll see as the new polls come
out in the next 7 to 10 days
now in terms of black lives matter I
don't believe that what's going on with
black lives matter is going to hurt
Democrats in November at all I think as
you pointed out from the beginning on
the main issue that rias attention on
black lives matter right now which were
the protests that started after the
death of George Floyd overwhelming
support for police reform reform support
for black lives matter itself is way up
compared to where it was you know two
months ago or just before the start of
this I think really the only risk is
what we've seen Republicans already try
to do which is to couch the protesters
as overwhelmingly violent or criminal
and it's mostly failed I mean like Trump
and Caylee Mac and Annie you know they
keep pushing it but I think people
pretty much know at this point that
protesters are protesting and that's the
majority of what's going on and then
other than that you have other people
who are participating and doing bad acts
but they're really not representative of
the movement so
I don't think it's going to hurt
Democrats in November okay yeah that
makes sense
one last thing and I've taken up a lot
of time but when do you think Biden will
announce his VP I think it's it should
should be obvious that it's Kamala
Harris but you know I think she would be
the best bet but would he wait until the
you know until what they're called until
the convention yeah he said it'll be
around it's he's gonna announce around
August first is what he said so I would
expect you know that's a month away I
would expect it will be roughly around
that time all right let's go to a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because I will go right back to the
phones right after this short break